ELON MUSK AUDIT.
ANYWAY.
MICHELLE WAS A HIGHLY RECOGNIZED
REPORTER FOR SPORTS, HUNDREDS OF
NFL GAMES AS A SIDELINE
REPORTER.
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN SOME OF HER
INTERVIEWS OVER THE YEARS.
HERE IS A SAMPLER.
INCLUDING FROM THE SUPER BOWL
THIS PAST SUNDAY.
>> OBVIOUSLY EMOTIONAL.
WHAT'S THE IMMEDIATE FEELING
YOU'VE GOT RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M JUST SO HAPPY.
I WANTED IT SO BAD.
I DREAMED OF THIS, MAN.
I DREAMED IT.
IT'S A REAL, LOOK AT THIS.
>> RETIRED FROM SPORTS.
MICHELLE, WE LOVE YOU.
WE WILL HEAR A LOT MORE FROM
HER.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS SUNDAY.
THIS IS WEDNESDAY AFTER NEARLY
30 YEARS COVER IN SPORTS,
MICHELLE HAS DECIDED TO STEP
AWAY FROM NBC SPORTS.
SHE SAID SHE MADE THE DECISION
FULLY ON HER OWN, SHE WAS NOT
FORCED OUT PURE CHEESE DOING IT
BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO BE IN A
ROLE WHERE SHE CAN SPEAK OPENLY.
IF NOTHING, WE ARE IN FAVOR OF
MORE THAN THAT.
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE HER JOIN
US TONIGHT TO EXPLAIN.
FIRST OF ALL, CONGRATULATIONS ON
THIS NEW CHAPTER.
WHAT AN INTERESTING DECISION
THAT YOU MADE.
WHY DID YOU MAKE IT?
>> IT'S BEEN ON MY MIND FOR
QUITE A WHILE, TALKER.
THANK YOU FOR HELPING ME.
NOW, AND BC DID NOT ENCOURAGE
THIS BEER THEY DID NOT FORCE
THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN ON MY MIND.
I HAVE BEEN WAKING UP EVERY DAY
WITH A PALPABLE PULL AT MY GUT
THAT MY MIDDLE GROUND,
MODERATE --
I WANT TO SHARE WITH THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
SO RATHER THAN BANGING IT OUT ON
TWITTER OR INSTAGRAM EVERY DAY,
I THOUGHT, I'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
I HAVE BENEFITED GREATLY FROM
THE AMERICAN DREAM AND I FEEL
LIKE FOR THE SAKE OF MY KIDS AND
BECAUSE I SO LOVE THIS COUNTRY,
I'VE GOT TO START GIVING BACK.
>> THAT IS THE BEST POSSIBLE
REASON.
SO PEOPLE WHO WATCH SPORTS KNOW
YOU AND HAVE FOR MANY YEARS.
HE WENT ON "THE VIEW" RECENTLY,
WHICH IS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
VENUE FOR YOU.
WE HAVE A SHORT CLIP AND I WANT
TO ASK IF THIS HAD SOME ROLE IN
YOUR DECISION.
HERE IT IS.
>> MY KIDS IN SCHOOL -- THERE IS
A BIG, BIG FOCUS ON THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN.
MY CHILDREN ARE NOW 16 AND 13.
IT HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE THEY
WERE IN LOWER SCHOOL.
IT IS THAT THERE IS AN AFFINITYY
GROUPS.
THEY WERE INSEPARABLE.
TO GET TO A CERTAIN AGE, THEY
START HAVING WHAT'S CALLED AN
AFFINITY GROUP WHICH MEANS YOU
GO FOR LUNCH AND PIZZA WITH
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE YOU.
SUDDENLY MY SON WASN'T HANGING
OUT WITH ANN ANYMORE.
WHY ARE WE EVEN TEACHING THAT
THE COLOR OF THE SKIN MATTERS?
TO ME WHAT MATTERS IS YOUR
CHARACTER AND YOUR VALUE.
>> YOU LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU KNOW THAT COLOR OF SKIN HAS
BEEN MATTER INTO PEOPLE --
>> CAN'T WE CHANGE IT?
>> WE NEED WHITE PEOPLE TO STEP
UP AND DO THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN DOING
THAT SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> NO, NO, KNOW THEY HAVEN'T!
>> Tucker: THAT WAS SUCH A
MODERATE THING TO SAY, SUCH A
SENSIBLE THING TO SAY.
AND YET IT SEEMS LIKE SUCH A
CONTROVERSIAL THING.
I THINK IT WAS REALLY BRAVE THAT
YOU SAID THAT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THE
REACTION?
>> AM JUST ASTONISHED THAT THAT
WE ARE SO LOOKING IN THE
REARVIEW MIRROR AND NOT
ABSORBING THE PROGRESS THAT WE
MADE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
BUILDING ON IT.
AND RECOGNIZING IT.
I DON'T THINK THAT WHOOPI
GOLDBERG WOULD HAVE THAT RULE 50
YEARS AGO.
AS SHE HAS THAT NOW.
YOU AND I KNOW, WE COULD COME UP
WITH A MILLION EXAMPLES.
AND IT BREAKS MY HEART THAT'S MY
KIDS ARE BEING TAUGHT THAT SKIN
COLOR MATTERS.
AND TO ME, IF YOU WANT WHITE
PEOPLE TO STEP UP, I WAS
STEPPING UP WHEN I ADDRESSED THE
SCHOOL AND SAID, WHY ARE WE
HAVING HIS PICNICS FOR FAMILIES
OF COLOR?
WHY ARE WE SEPARATING OUR KIDS?
IF THE WORLD IS INTEGRATED,
LET'S CONTINUE THAT AND HAVE
EVERYONE FIND OUT WHAT WE ALL
HAVE IN COMMON, NOT JUST WHAT WE
HAVE IN COMMON WITH PEOPLE WHO
LOOK LIKE US.
>> Tucker: MAN.
I BET YOU 20 BUCKS THAT 95% OF
AMERICANS AGREE WITH WHAT YOU
JUST SAID.
BUT TO SAY THAT WHEN YOU WORK AT
NBC SPORTS OR ANY BIG MEDIA
COMPANY REALLY TAKES -- SHE
MUST'VE KNOWN THAT YOU WOULD BE
ATTACKED FOR DEFENDING THE
AMERICAN IDEAL AS YOU DID.
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
>> BECAUSE I DON'T CARE IF I'M
ATTACKED.
I REALLY AM NOT AFRAID OF THAT.
AND I GUESS I FEEL LIKE SO MANY
PEOPLE NOW ARE AFRAID.
AND I'M NOT.
LISTEN, I KNOW THERE ARE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR WHATEVER I
CHOOSE TO SAY.
AND I'VE TALKED TO MIKE AT
SCHOOL ABOUT IT.
PLEASE DON'T HOLD THIS AGAINST
MY KIDS, I'M SPEAKING FOR ME,
I'M SPEAKING FROM A FAMILY, BUT
PLEASE DON'T HOLD THIS AGAINST
MY KIDS.
I THINK I SPEAK FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE, LIKE YOU SAID, AND A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE, MY FRIENDS, ARE
AFRAID TO REPOST THINGS THAT
I'VE POSTED OR GET INTO
POLITICAL CONVERSATIONS.
THEY ARE, AND I'VE SAID IT, I'M
AFRAID.
I DON'T WANT TO GET IN THESE
ARGUMENTS WITH MY FRIENDS, WITH
MY BALLS, WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS THE MOST TERRIFYING
THING IN THE WORLD TO ME RIGHT
NOW.
THAT PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO TALK.
THESE ARE WORDS COMING OUT OF
OUR MOUTH.
YES, WE COULD PROBABLY HURT
PEOPLE WITH OUR WORDS, I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
BUT I GET TO CHOOSE MY REACTION
TO EVERYBODY'S WORDS.
AND EVERYBODY ELSE GETS TO
CHOOSE THEIR REACTION TO MY
WORDS.
THEY CAN CHOOSE TO REACT TO WHAT
I SAY.
I'M GOING TO CHOOSE TO SAY WHAT
I BELIEVE AND WHAT I FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE THIS.
THIS IS THE DIRECTION I'M
HEADED.
>> I JUST LOVE IT, SO MUCH.
I THINK PERSONAL BRAVERY LIKE
THE KIND THAT YOU HAVE DISPLAYED
AND ARE DISPLAYING NOW IS DEEPLY
INSPIRING TO PEOPLE AND
COMFORTING AND REALLY IS THE
ANSWER TO WHERE WE ARE.
SO THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
>> I HOPE PEOPLE WILL J